tja das sind aussagen die eine gänsehaut
machen der autor des films rio seppelt
ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet guten morgen
heiko ich hoffe der tone stetig konnte
ich gerade nicht so gut verstehen
beschreibt unser bitte deine erfahrungen
bei den recherchen zu diesem film
das war ein team eine teamarbeit die wir
da hatten wir mit katharina kühn meiner
co autoren ohne die das ganze gar nicht
realisierbar gewesen wäre
2013 habe ich angefangen mich mit der
thematik zu beschäftigen
ich bin selber katholisch sozialisiert
war ministrant war lektor aber 2013 ich
mir die hutschnur gerissen als papst
benedikt damals wieder mal
frauenfeindliche äußerungen von sich gab
damit ich ausgetreten aus der kirche
aber an dem thema blieb ich dann
journalistisch dran weil es mich einfach
interessiert hat diese heuchelei diese
doppelbödigkeit in der kirche des
journalistisch reizvoll ist übrigens gar
nicht so weit entfernt von dem was man
im internationalen sport bis dahin
erlebt und dann habe ich das thema dann
ein paar jahre später wieder aufgenommen
mit katharina zusammen und es ist uns
gelungen 100 menschen heranzukommen und
man könnte sagen es war fast am ende
natürlich eine ganz tolle geschichte das
gleichzeitig eine initiative mit dem
namen out in church sich formierte vor
einem jahr war das und wir haben dann
recherchiert diese initiative hat sich
dann formiert und so kommt es nun zu
diesem großen ich finde schon
einzigartigen hdtv projekt auf den
shirts darüber sprechen wir gleich auch
noch mit dem initiator direkt im
anschluss an ein interview beschreibt
doch noch mal wie schwierig war das
überhaupt an diese protagonisten
ranzukommen es ist ein riesen tabuthema
niemand spricht darüber und ihr ruf dann
an und sagt hey möchtest du hier
auspacken oder wie kann man sich das
vorstellen
so kann man sich das garantiert nicht
vorstellen das war dann ein bisschen
anders also vor allem irgendeine
kollegin katharina kühn hat den kontakt
gesucht nachdem wir natürlich auch mit
authentisch zusammengearbeitet haben
respektive von dort auch kontakte
bekommen hatte und von menschen die
bereit gewesen waren mit uns zu sprechen
aber mit uns zu sprechen und dann auch
vor die kamera zu treten das sind zwei
verschiedene dinge denn sie müssen angst
haben dass sie ihren arbeitsplatz
verlieren und weil sie mit einer
beispielsweise gleichgeschlechtlichen
partnerschaft gegen die sogenannte
grundordnung für menschen im kirchlichen
dienst verstoßen und insofern war das
gar nicht so einfach aber viele haben
sich dann doch gewagt wir haben
insgesamt 100 interviews gemacht alle in
der ard mediathek übrigens zu sehen
neben der doku die jetzt bereits online
ist und diese menschen sind zu 80
prozent ist 80 oder 81 genau die sind
offen vor die kamera getreten aber eben
19 nicht und das zeigt dass es erneut
immer noch oder befehlen weiter ängste
gibt ängste gibt dass sie ihren
arbeitsplatz verlieren können dass sie
diskriminiert werden dass sie
ausgeschlossen werden und das ist halt
eine angst die immer noch da ist wir
sind neben im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert insofern ist das schon alles
sehr sehr befremdlich mein eindruck ist
dass die gesellschaft in deutschland
lichtjahre voraus ist von manchen doch
eher versteinerten verknöcherten
kirchenvertreter vielen dank rio seppelt
und dann sprechen wir jetzt mit an der
betroffenen und zwar mit jens ehebrechen
sandte dem initiator von autoservice
kirchlicher angestellter im vikariat des
bistums hamburg schönen guten tag
welcher verlusten im moment war es der
sie zu dieser initiative gebracht hat
und wie schwierig war es dann menschen
zu finden die mitmachen
der schlüsselmoment war tatsächlich am 5
februar morgens direkt ort kampagne der
185 schauspielerin die sich geoutet
haben und als ich das morgens aufschlug
und lars hab ich gedacht wow respekt und
das brauchen wir in der kirche auch und
dann habe ich das so über meine
social-media-kanäle auch raus getwittert
und rausgeschickt und bekam sofort von
ganz vielen kolleginnen zustimmung und
ich hab dann einen der kollegen der
dokumentiert hat angerufen bernd menke
besser vermeiden haben und wir zwei
haben das ganze dann in die hand
genommen und so in unseren persönlichen
netzwerken kolleginnen eingeladen
erzählen sie uns doch mal so ein
bisschen von dem alltag der
homosexuellen mitarbeiter der
katholischen kirche was passiert da
alles
ja wir haben tatsächlich in unserer
runde einige dabei für die das jetzt
auch ihr coming out ist selbst im
persönlichen umfeld und das heißt das
dass menschen sind die teilweise schon
seit jahren jahrzehnten im kirchlichen
dienst sind und nie mit jemandem aus
ihrem beruflichen oder privaten umfeld
über ihre eigene identität sexualität
gesprochen haben das heißt ein großteil
auch der der energie wird darauf
verwandt etwas sehr wesentliches von
sich zu verheimlichen und wenn man sich
dann vorstellen dass wir sind ja
menschen die in der seelsorge arbeiten
in der beratung religionslehrerinnen
also menschen die sehr viel
beziehungsarbeit sozusagen machen und
wenn ich dann aber selber als person
mich gar nicht zeigen kann dann ist das
ein widerspruch in sich und spricht
eigentlich gegen alles wofür wir als
kirche stehen
was sind ihre forderungen jetzt an die
kirche damit sich in zukunft auch noch
mehr homosexuelle mitarbeiter trauen
sich offen zu bekennen
ja wir haben ein langes manifest
geschrieben und haben dann gemerkt wir
müssen das noch mal auf den punkt
bringen und haben dann sieben
kernforderungen heraus geschrieben die
drehen sich natürlich um das ganze thema
wir brauchen so eine kultur von vielfalt
und anerkennung und ich glaube die
forderung die jetzt am stärksten ist und
auch am meisten abrufbar ist eine
sichtbare und reelle veränderung des
kirchlichen arbeitsrecht es das was hajo
seppelt eben gesagt hat diese
sogenannten loyalitäts klauseln das ist
etwas was wir fordern ist es aus dem
arbeitsrecht hinaus gestrichen wird oder
dass das gelockert wird das niemanden
mehr der zum beispiel seine sein partner
ihre frau heiratet den job verliert und
viele in unserer gruppe sind trans
personen für diese kolleginnen ist die
situation noch viel prekärer
wir haben berufsverbote für diese
menschen haben berufsverbote für schwule
männer die priester werden wollen das
sind dinge die wir nicht akzeptieren
möchten eine sehr mutige initiative
großen respekt dafür vielen dank für das
gespräch herr selbe recht zumsande
vielen dank
[Musik]
was denken sie über dieses große thema
das so klein gehalten wird wie sehen sie
das outing homosexueller
kirchenmitarbeiter was erwarten sie
jetzt von der kirche wir haben sie auf
der straße in frankfurter meinung gehört
wir möchten jetzt wissen wie muss die
katholische kirche auf dieses outing
reagieren ja sie müssen in die offensive
gehen und
jeden priester natürlich bei stehen sie
unterstützen auch in der öffentlichkeit
aber ich glaube nicht dass es passieren
wird die kirche hat in letzter zeit oft
alles dann ja tot geschwiegen jetzt auch
in den neuesten enthüllungen
aus münchen hat der papst sich nicht
dazu geäußert und ich glaube dass es
diesmal da keinen großen keine großen
handlungen geben wird und dass die
katholische kirche das einfach unter den
teppich kehren wird und einfach so
weitermachen wird also ich hoffe
natürlich nicht dass das totgeschwiegen
wird oder genauso in der versenkung
wieder verschwindet wie es gekommen ist
ja und wünscht den herrschaften alles
gute das sie da offen
resonanz bekommen und dass das so weit
doch alles ein gutes feedback wenn sich
solche solche spannungen aufbauen über
lange zeit und nicht abgearbeitet werden
sondern einfach nur ignoriert werde
untergeschoben wird werden dann dann
einlädt sich das und das passiert jetzt
gerade also gott steht ja viel liebe
generell und gott liebt alle menschen
erlebt alle lebewesen und insofern
sollte es absolut wichtig sein dass die
oberen in der katholischen kirche sich
sehr positiv dazu bekennen müssten und
sagen wir lieben die menschen so wie sie
sind und gott hat sie so geschaffen und
insofern eine sollte eine absolut
positive reaktion darauf erfolgen aber
ich finde es toll diese aktion und von
meiner seite aus der absolute
unterstützung
[Musik]